[Music]
this is it
dresses by ella
here's a laugh this girl fancies herself
a businessman
cinderella it's only my love for your
father rest [ __ ]
that stands between you and a life on
the street i have to make a life for
myself
you'll sell one of my signature dresses
soon everyone will love my name
to make sure your nuptials are done
properly we shall hold a ball
you shall find a bride
cinderella you don't need to go to the
ball please stepmother i spent weeks
making this dress my future depends on
it
yes i am your fabulous godmother
do you want to go to that ball and meet
a bunch of rich people who will change
your life
yes i was just crying and singing about
it like two minutes ago
you shall oh look at that
this is different okay dad you said you
wanted to be a businesswoman
it's magic time oh me
where's my tail i can't balance without
my cat
[Music]
hi would you like to dance right now
where did you get that dress i designed
it i pick you to be my princess what
about my work
i don't want a life stuck waving from a
royal box any more than a life confined
to a basement
[Music]
it's too late
life outside this basement starts right
[Music]
now
the glass any way you can make it more
comfortable no but you just did a whole
thing
even magic has its limits
[Music]
so
bye